school's out but infections are up and
with cases jumping in children 12 to 15
year olds can now join those booking
jabs online 14 year old joseph's already
had his it just felt right to get it
because
after being in lockdown for six of
months it i'd seen what it was like to
just be locked in a room locked in a
house for that long
so i just did not want that to happen i
think it's really important especially
with the rise in the age range because
they've had many cases
and before
the last lockdown of course it meant
that the whole year group would have to
close gelja told me she wanted her 12
year old jabbed even though there's a
bit of hesitation
yeah we still um let him have the first
job and he wasn't worried about that no
nothing and then also after the job he
was fine completely fine no temperature
at all just a little bit of tenderness
but it was fine
but neither keyana nor her mum tyr are
convinced i'm going to give it a couple
more years to see what's going on and
then
she will have i don't want to be
pressured and rushed into anything
because
right now they don't really know what's
going on themselves
in england the rollout among children
has been slow but in scotland drop-in
clinics and a special bus have sped
things up and teenage vaccination rates
are much higher i was at a vaccine
clinic yesterday and there were many
young people i assume in that age group
just dropping in a couple of our more
rural health boards they've still been
doing it in schools or with appointments
but i think the convenience we reached
50 just yesterday i think is the biggest
driver
the government says it doesn't want to
reintroduce restrictions which is why
for now ministers are sticking with plan
a to get as many as possible vaccinated
from first jabs to boosters
this clinic in birkenhead was busy but
rates across the country remain slow if
you ask my professional colleagues in
the hospital they'll tell you that the
people who are going to the hospital are
younger people
who have not been vaccinated so the vast
majority of the people who are being
admitted to hospital are unvaccinated
and more younger population 12 months
ago it was we were all talking about
older people vulnerable people now it is
the unvaccinated younger people who are
becoming the vulnerable people and
perhaps a sign there are worries number
10s ask the former vaccine chief to
return to her role
the half-term holiday has started but
there's no break from covid the
government needs vaccine rates high to
help keep infections down
and time meanwhile is running out laura
bundock sky news